today on our show look in the sky it's
bird it's plane
it's girls girls Supergirl I directed
her that's right another episode of
Supergirl I directed and we're gonna
talk about it along with a bunch of
other cool news shoes right here right
now on Batman on Batman
[Music]
well then the fat man I'm Batman I'm
Kevin Smith I'm not how are you handling
there's as far as this bat or that's my
wind-ups cry yeah how can you just leave
me standing mark alone in the world so
cold I'm sorry
maybe you're just too demanding just
like my father too old to bolt wasn't an
old gold is it old but will be just like
I guess you make more sense baby just
like my father too old
why would you sing that fool was like no
it was maybe I'm just like my father
and you wouldn't say that to a girl I'm
too old for you especially because he
was I think it's bull he might have been
too short for she was taller true but he
had the heels minute later it all makes
sense though because prince sang bad
genes everything and it brings us right
back to our show princes the unified
theory of feminine Hey Supergirl airs
this week and I saw a trailer at the end
of the last episode of Supergirl and it
looked like a fun episode in the middle
of it it said from the mind of Kevin
Smith from your mind yeah I found that
hard to believe I really credit the
writers it's been their minds game
banana but but I you know I think we did
a pretty good job Megan it's pretty fun
episode I got to go to space again space
leg yeah well kind of lower space
because the daksa might ships in orbit
if you watch the recent episodes you
know that teri hatcher is the queen of
daksa m-- and kevin sorbo is the king of
daksa m-- and they finally showed up
looking for their son the Prince of Dax
them who is spoilers Mon L Chris would
like my [ __ ] one of my favorite
actors on the planet I think that'd be
so funny yeah um yeah wood for wood yeah
big wood if no one else can
Chris wood that's what I do in any event
they are so most of our episode takes
place on the ship and you know the
troposphere and we have a reappearance
by the transmatterer portal that we had
debuted in my episode like where they
jumped over to the planet where
other planet [ __ ] like slavers moon so
the transmatter portal comes back and
plays a role it's pretty and the full
move that movie episode flat-out opens
with her fighting a [ __ ] alien with a
big rubber mask that's amazing it's
pretty dubbed there was one moment where
we were in the middle of Vancouver
shooting in front of a church and [ __ ] I
was just like I went to film school
three blocks from here never once did I
imagine when I walked past this Church
in this park I'd returned here twenty
[ __ ] five years later with a dude and
a big goofy rubber mask and the [ __ ]
maid in the mic just like pam pam just
punching him it all comes around life
was good oh so good so it's fun episode
man and those kids are wonderful Melissa
and Chris together Melissa is just
wonderful period I just did a PaleyFest
this week I saw it all over the
Internet's I was hosting the Pirelli Fed
moderating not hosting the Paley people
don't hosted it and they held it at the
Dolby theater where the Oscars had just
been set allowed me to open with like
let me enjoy this is the closest I'll
ever get to the Oscar stage and stuff I
was like hahaha it's funny because it's
true and and then just you wait yeah is
like one day just you wait and retake it
was just the place went quiet as I
[ __ ] silently saying that like it's
bad from my fair lady like yeah be
singing it like he's part of the
lollipops angry he's very confused panel
was wonderful we only had like 90
minutes but everybody got a question and
then we did open up for the audience
which is more important to me of course
there were some people on Twitter who
were like this sucks and he sucks and
everything about this sucks that he
should go to hell and he's a fat [ __ ]
idiot and he sucks I am all those things
just so you feel better about yourself
but largely people seem to like the
panel my moderation job they were just
jealous they weren't there I've no there
they see there seem to be people that
were just like why didn't you give more
time to X Y & Z but it's like everybody
got a question like I had what like 30
people in that [ __ ] panel it's pretty
big panel we had a lot of the producers
and we had like two people from each
show
the cast of the cast of each show but
and then we opened up to the audience I
thought it was lovely though and you
know I've told the same [ __ ] stale
jokes about like you know I didn't watch
these shows until [ __ ] the King shark
up so tough but it was it was great such
a great panel but anyway why don't we
were doing the panel like I stopped mid
panel and just sucked her dick so hard
cuz she's honestly like now worked with
her twice Melissa like just the goods
dude like she's true talent you hand her
[ __ ] these pages like we're about to
roll I just wrote this [ __ ] say it
and bam she spits it out like she was
thinking it herself such a natural so
talent like at that level we need a lead
of a show right this goes without saying
you're talented but man like this girl
works like 96 hours a day and never
complains like that's her only fault is
that she won't like [ __ ] be like I
need rest
like stop she can't defend herself she
can defend the world but you can't
[ __ ] defend herself but so she's so
damn wonderful man I'll go back anytime
they want me to [ __ ] work with her but
I I know the benefit of don't go and do
those shows is I know what's happening
from now until the end of the season and
I also know what happens next season but
I'm gonna tell you right now tell me it
[ __ ] makes me cry Andrew Kreisberg
[ __ ] tip and told me everything and I
like instantly was rollin tears it is so
[ __ ] good
he also like I've known what happens on
flash for a while tonight right now is
the musical episode that's Aaron I can't
wait to watch that but I know what
happens and flash this season and it is
is a tearjerker there's so many [ __ ]
like sorry I love these shows those
shows those two shows in particular are
my [ __ ] religion I put time aside and
watch them all the time
and there's a reason man like I just I'm
there my soap operas I love the stories
that they're telling I love that they're
all friends they all give a [ __ ] about
it each other but I love that they have
superpowers you know what I'm saying
it's just like the way my grandmother
watch Young and the Restless
it's like Young and the Restless but
they all got superpowers
and so periodically something cool
happens we're like look at our feet of
physical fury but my favorite parts of
those shows are like the really human
aspects of so I he told me some [ __ ]
that they're doing which as a DC fan
made me just nuts spontaneously in my
[ __ ] pants but also as somebody that
just likes good stories I was like
that's fantastic
excellent they got excellent good [ __ ]
coming up man I look forward to [ __ ]
the end of this season Supergirl but the
beginning and the all next season it's
well going place anyway so that that
episode airs the episode that I directed
second one that I got credit for
directing I don't really directed I give
credit so like James James Liston James
Sonny Liston our DP is wonderful shooter
he made this show look like it does an
Armand the guy who does our arming porky
and I think it was last name he does the
effects on all those [ __ ] CW shows he
makes flash run fast he makes Supergirl
fly he made King shark he made Grodd you
watch the Grodd I totally do those dude
we watched like [ __ ] gorilla City
invade Earth and what's more we went to
gorilla City and saw Sala bar yeah like
which is outstanding the idea that you
can have gorilla city on network
television that doesn't look like [ __ ]
at home it looked like you know that
paintings they only had so much money so
everyone's in a cage going like god
Barry shout out a window and stuff but
well like don't matter because then they
cut to a shot a [ __ ] like flash
fighting Sala var in a dust bowled arena
surprise shapes are going on television
yeah yeah yeah yeah you kids take this
[ __ ] for granted we used to have to pay
good money to see this [ __ ] in a movie
theater I go to see Kong Skull Island
that's not bad also we made movie
theater they spent hundred million
dollars on they spent six on the outside
haha
tops and more good gorilla city that's
crazy that's so they're doing the Lord's
work over there on the CW
I don't care anybody says different is
entitled to their opinion but [ __ ] I
love what they do and I love what they
told me is coming
and hopefully you love the episode I
directed which is on Monday Monday June
Monday Sunday the next time supergirls
on this will go up very soon
next time supergirls on I believe I'm
the guy that directed the episode from
the mind of this guy yeah I saw that in
the trailer that's crazy
alright like why would you use my name
to market anything alright moving on
let's talk about this very sad news for
comic book lovers everywhere for art
lovers everywhere for storyteller lovers
everywhere and for people that just like
good guys who didn't live long enough
didn't live long enough lives to match
their gigantic [ __ ] talents it's a
long way of saying Bernie Wrightson
passed away indeed for those who are
like who's Bernie Wrightson come on are
you watching the show for but you know
I'm not gonna [ __ ] curse you darkest
I'm gonna light a candle you'll know who
it is
let me introduce you to the work of
burning rites and burning rites and
co-creator with Len Wein of The Swamp
Thing you ain't got no [ __ ] Swamp
Thing Frankenstein Frankenstein he did
this amazing [ __ ] Frankenstein work
who's that from Marvel's portfolio of
just these amazing crust hatch
beautifully detailed shots of the
monster and dr. Frankenstein you know
Diana would a pencil did that kids yeah
um look at looking at the darkness look
at the shading that's that's the stuff
that I fell in love with like I was
never that big of a Swamp Thing fan and
so much later
one more turn me on swampy yeah but like
that stuff was just like I couldn't
believe a person drew that and also like
remember he worked with Gaiman on
Sandman issues our covers remember he
did creep show yeah I mean he was he's
the art and creep show when you see
creep show that's Bernie right see he
was a he was a working artist who worked
for Marvel work for DC worked for indie
companies work worked when he can work
because that's what you did when it's
that 70s 80s and 90s and you're an
artist who's just making a buck but the
buck that he made the work that he gave
us was outstanding stellar and like you
know I probably say too often for it to
matter anymore but if there was a Mount
Rushmore for comic book artists yeah
he's one of those [ __ ] faces on it
and you know he very mild very may well
have been just a one of the faces on a
Mount Rushmore for artists period not
just compo cars but we celebrate the man
for his comic book work which was
[ __ ] astounding Swan things an
amazing character and looks visually
fantastic yeah your eyes drawn to
Atlantis man's work was amazing and a
lot of people in our line of work
wouldn't do what they do were not for
people like him seeing that stuff when
you were kid going like oh my god I want
to be involved in some way shape or form
fandom takes that shape he fanned the
flames of fandom and not even by being a
guy that went out there and [ __ ]
pressed the flesh he was just so [ __ ]
spellbinding ly good at his job
he created fandom around himself and
fandom for a medium that like people
that I don't even have artistic [ __ ]
talent now I was like I want to be in
comics somehow that's how good an artist
and like the stories that I had heard of
people who knew him who were friends
with him were nothing but the nicest guy
in the world who would like chicken on
you if you just moved to town and you
didn't you know know anybody and your
family was a lunch settled he would stop
by once a week for years to make sure
that you were okay and bring over dinner
and hang out with the kids and Neil
Gaiman just put a Twitter of on Twitter
picture of him Bernie Wrightson Frank
Miller when they were kids like in their
20s whatever [ __ ] 30s and my god they
look so young and stuff but he speaking
to young he was not that old
you know like early sixties I think it
was I don't know what a brain cancer I
think Iran or something [ __ ] so
goddamn unfair but leave sit behind a
massive legacy of body of work I'm sure
he leaves family behind us well that
legacies far more important but the work
is gonna live forever man forever people
will be looking at stuff as Gustave doré
a good-looking yeah as woodcut good so
Bernie Wrightson guys salute yeah
rest in peace genius genius like me
literally what [ __ ] genius what else
you call me let's start let's go on a
news that's not so depressing no what's
this about apparently
Robert Downey jr. wants to talk to the
animals
so he's starring in the voyages of dr.
Dolittle
so from Eddie Murphy mm-hmm to Robert
Downey jr. from and who's the first of
the Rex Reed Rex Harrison Rex Harrison
it was a Rex make sure we hit the film
critic Wow and he didn't like it no
ironically enough the [ __ ] I'm in this
movie was a kind of like the lead Rex
Harrison yeah Wow so he's gonna alright
so but it's interesting to me written
and directed by Stephen Gaghan yes this
guy did in Syria Syria won an Oscar for
writing Travis is now doing the voyages
of Doctor Doom from the director serious
comes animals talk maybe it's a real
[ __ ] serious treatment maybe they
ain't like maybe it's like Sherlock
Holmes where he's like if I punched the
monkey in the face I can take down a
talking game if I talk to this dragon I
wonder what I'm in you know why cuz
Robert Downey jr. is Bob look I also
like Stephen Gaghan so if Stephen Gaghan
is like you know what [ __ ] all those
depressing movies I normally make what
you're brilliant but really sad yeah
[ __ ] Syria where the boy gets killed
spoilers in a [ __ ] pool yep there's
like a loose wire I haven't gone in my
swimming pools gets the only real first
of all problem but I haven't gotten my
inground swimming pool delight in it
since I what's that movie same way that
Steven Spielberg chased me out of the
ocean with a fish [ __ ] story when I
was a child
Stephen Gaghan chased me out of my own
goddamn pool just lays there with Rob
just like Spielberg chased me out of his
backyard yeah I want to swim music [ __ ]
out your Pappy's and you know okay
shinebox
I say it's the guys made clerks it goes
yeah so in any event yeah that's
happening Stephen Gaghan is a great
choice but Robert Downey jr. I'll watch
him do anything yeah this is gonna sound
creepy but I've watched him [ __ ] my
wife and I'm not a cuckold but that's
what I'm saying he's so good at what he
does I'd watch him do that and it would
hurt like I'd tell my wife later on like
why why why did you agree to it you know
but still
what's the because of the money but he
was good at it did he do this weird
just saying I like the man's work that's
all I'm sure I could find a better way
Express I'm so I'm in for that next up
we got this news dropped and I'm like
whoa what you know what we might need to
do let's save that into a whole [ __ ]
show there enough totally on the next
episode Wow matrix again question mark
we'll do that later on look at behind us
oh so cool tune in for our thoughts on
that's great yeah and what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna matrix you guys Sony is moving
forward with a venom standalone movie
set for release 2018 yeah they're not
[ __ ] around now this is the
spider-man that we know and love Tom
Owen uh probably so that means they got
to introduce venom beforehand are they
gonna introduce him with does that mean
he's in homecoming it also marks what
are the answers
it all sounds a little bit dodgy almost
only in that they would have to
absolutely do all that shoe leather and
and like okay so homecoming doesn't just
have to reintroduce spider-man as the
star of his own movie doesn't have to
also feature you know voltar doesn't
also have to incorporate our deejaying
away and Tony Stark but you've got a
seed venom as well well what does that
movie come out I'm coming this July
Independence Day I think 2017 and this
is coming out in a year like a year and
change after that October 2018 so bad to
gas
I mean unless they're in to know that
it's not gonna introduce Eddie Brock in
maybe but that seems like a lot of shoe
leather unless it's this movie will
introduce venom to then play a part in
spider-man homecoming 2 which you know
I'm not gonna be like the dick that's
like hey man venom comes from
spider-man's [ __ ] suit from space
yeah it's the symbiotic suit for
Christ's sakes it's the symbiotic say
they gotta do that look at ya
then out whatever they're doing with
this [ __ ] new spider-man that new
spider-man could [ __ ] my wife that's how
[ __ ] good I that new spider-man is
using the web people like a lot of those
Marvel heroes to [ __ ] your wife yes I do
um yeah man [ __ ] jeez that's if it's
those guys and it's that Kevin Feige I
gotta hand in this
the the press did not mention his name
I'm about to put my money down just say
yes I did not to this point my money is
hovering I'm about to lay it on the
table the moment somebody says Kevin
Feige he's overseeing this I mean I
would imagine he has to have some say
right you know there's my money in a way
it's about enough species enough but it
seems like Sony's been trying to sort of
spin off their spider in the universe
for a while like they were gonna do yeah
yeah back sinister so in the second
spider-man they wanted to do sinister 6
which died on the vine because because
whoa Kevin Feige right toys back and I
got to play with spider-man in Civil War
yes Simha sistex was supposed to be
directed and written by Drew Goddard the
guy that left daredevil to go do that
yes and then was Oscar nominated for the
Martian he's fine yeah okay so [ __ ] yeah
all right venom I'm all for it hey man
gotta be better than the last venom go
around I thought you say it's gotta be
better than Iron Fist which I would
probably say yes again yeah I mean I'm
not [ __ ] on anybody but I did not
prefer the Topher Grace version of that
no character like I love Sam Raimi but
that was not the best execution other
spider-man thing Nate too much that was
in those days when they put like 19
villains in a movie and now they just
put a ring of [ __ ] floating garbage
in the sky with a laser kind of whatever
you heard active yeah there was an
alternate rogue one ending you say yeah
that's according to screenwriter Gary
Whitta and what'd he say he said and
I'll read it I'm single hold it up so
you hold it up every read off the
prompter yeah there we go
jyn erso and Kashi and or don't transmit
the Death Star schematics for the
rebellion
instead they bring it themselves in a
shuttle with Vader hot on their heels
after a fight during which Jim Tessie
transferring information from the data
tapes to the tenth or for failure
ultimately breaches the seal the shuttle
shields he destroys the craft at every
one end or so we think
Vader leads to pursue the tenth before
the camera would then focus on what's
left in the shuttle Jin and Cassie and
survived in their escape pod which
floats away like debris just like the
Millennium Falcon did in the Empire
Strikes Back when it said the fact that
we had to jump through so many hoops to
keep them alive I would like to hire you
for clerks three well that's interesting
you heard with perd yeah that's a little
I mean I get it something would be fun
just from Entertainment Weekly
there's no weekly is our is our source
for this ah uh yeah I prefer what they
did in the movie kill them all yeah I
like the Bell died
look God sort of matter or the Jedi but
that the Darth Vader Sam you know
pursuing them sounds kind of cool but
I'm happy with what I got yeah and like
we still get Darth Vader pursuing them
anyway you get the first shot of him
like [ __ ] hanging out with those
turns a [ __ ] off maybe I'm remembering
it wrong with Ben it lives in our hearts
amazing I was amazing minify was my
favorite minute of film in the last 10
years I can watch that one minute of
film over and over again I hope that's
what I see when I die over and over that
one minute of just like oh my god he
turned on a lightsaber in the dark holy
[ __ ] he split that [ __ ] in half in the
roof did you see the [ __ ] screaming
help
all of this was fantastic and a positive
a total good that's my idea have one
minute of road one
watch as I [ __ ] love the married man
begin pop culture come weird asthmatic
[Applause]
[Laughter]
last piece of information we're gonna
leave you with folks yes Sylvester
Stallone and Michael Rosenbaum Rosenbaum
who played Sylvester Stallone I forget
what he played but I know right Michael
Rosenbaum played Lex Luthor on
Smallville Sylvester Stallone I believe
was in a picture called the Lords of
Flatbush and stop my mumbles yeah that's
right I think he had a part in that and
Rhinestone it's very memorable role
that's known for and wasn't Oscar indeed
hmm those two cats are going to be in
James Gunn's new photo play guardians of
the galaxy volume dogies according to
James Gunn as he revealed on the Adam
Carolla Show
I'll read the syllabus oh wait
characters yeah that's your James Gunn
that's that is my super excited news
reader okay I was getting his big shot
at like to them to get the Today Show
I'm gonna get them notice me this is
Albert Brooks and broadcasts what I
gotta get out of this shitty market I
gotta get to the big show give a single
wait up a couple of guys these were very
important to the Marvel Universe you
were going to make their debut it guards
in the yard see William to which people
don't know about
he told Corolla Sylvester Stallone plays
one of these characters my friend
Michael Rosenbaum also has a pretty
decent movie in the role role in the
movie
well and it sort of works in tandem with
a sli's character this has been perhaps
you heard with perd back to you you've
got a character yeah he's got a look at
introduced a new character on the show
like I stole the character from Parks
and Recreation Oh what is what I stole
me no all I do go to picture book that's
exciting news whoo let's speculate ooh I
got no guesses
could they be like in the Nova Corps
what if one of them was Noah what if it
was just like [ __ ] everybody Michael
Rosenbaum is Nova would be mad you know
be happy everybody especially everybody
who is like a small little family be
like good for him [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] a
way to do I met him he's a nice guy make
him know Bob felt like Jesus he has a
part you'd have my [ __ ] face what
more do you want me to do I don't give a
[ __ ] what they do in that movie that
movie has all of the money an odd weight
as my money as there's money imma borrow
money from him so I could pay to see it
again do it again we're gonna [ __ ] him
we're gonna rob a bank and use a bank's
money they're gonna sell that money for
gold bullion and then transfer it back
into money and then buy bitcoins and buy
[ __ ] online bitcoins aren't that stable
too much right
we're gonna stay outta bitcoins but
other than that heists [ __ ] exchange
rates whatever it takes
michael rooker not only all over the
trailer now all over the posters well to
make plays a big part man he's literally
becomes one of the guardians got himself
a promotion I work to them I knew him
when you know master spending that's all
oh wait one last piece yeah I mean I'd
mentioned it in one of those summer
shows that we did while you were up
there do boarding with super heroes and
God I don't know if you guys know this
for that director the second episode of
Supergirl that airs this week I'm
boarding with extraterrestrial this dude
son that's what I called thanks very
good yes that Nightwing is getting a
solo movie to be directed by Chris McKay
coming off with a Lego Batman picture
kind of amazing world of Wonders do we
live in now that [ __ ] night wings
gonna get a movie is it setting that we
don't know if it's set in the DC
it is extended so he'll know that Batman
he will know a battery and that battery
Batman couldn't he know but he might
know before he could go back like maybe
that was the suit no that was Robin yeah
I mean you know I thought he got killed
we all [ __ ] screw you
oh dude oh wait Oh Paxton died while we
were where he did I I did eulogize him
as well while you were cavorting with
gods and heroes but by all means the
Praxis begin it's amazing performer man
lunch put her in charge I'll think of
that alias performance from now until
the day I die aliens maybe not every
[ __ ] day but whenever I think Alan's
the first thing that comes to my mind is
his performance if you ask me what is
the best movie you've ever seen aliens
is at the top of that list for me not my
favorite movie
there are favorite movies I have above
that but I still think aliens is maybe
the best made movie I've ever seen
look I wouldn't you know beautiful is
pure movie bliss yeah takes a really
good idea and runs with it things a good
idea hey remember where the alien plural
sealing more aliens but he was
astounding it was wonderful on course
weird science but Bach dude and then him
and aliens him and anything dude was the
[ __ ] cartilage of anything is that I
mean wonderful perform all 13 big love
you know everything he's ever been
[ __ ] true lies he's super fun in True
Lies the only man who was killed by a
predator Terminator and an alien the
trifecta there it is
but you can only dream to be that
[ __ ] live a life that big Bill Paxton
rarities Bernie Wrightson rest in peace
to many brilliant people dead one day
that'll be us but non brilliance Oh
another news these [ __ ]
hey dis objec they appreciated a lot of
[ __ ] but cool people did I always feel
like whenever I'm flying in a plane and
I know that there's somebody famous on
that plane that that'll be the story
it's like Denzel Washington and unnamed
a black guy died in the fiery play X is
better get to work if you want to
I mean look if I die in a flame with
Denzel Washington it's gonna be dental
watch and that guy died Wayne believe me
Denzel Washington Trump's all yeah lower
the bar here's my advice to you the
moment you see Denzel Washington get a
plane don't go hey tiny Lister all right
you and me buddy we can ride this clown
you might you might get a mention I
might get a mention your fabulous but
not against Denzel heaven yeah that's it
that's all these we got for you who's
gonna drag the night wing movie Chris
McKay the guy that did the Lego Batman
yes I love that movie I love this movie
I'm in the bag for this [ __ ]
if you came to watch me [ __ ] [ __ ] on
it that ain't this nope that ain't me
babe
that ain't me you're lookin for its mark
he is it yeah I'll [ __ ] on there it is
for fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm the guy who shoots out everything
come back next week and watch him crap
all over some bad times ain't backin
swirls against God more dot-com slash
Kevin Smith he's doing a Tom Carvel
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]